rendre le cheval populaire attirer les
quelques 8 millions de français qui
disent selon les enquêtes qu'ils
aimeraient faire du cheval
tel est le pari de ces journée nationale
du cheval et du poney montré par exemple
que le cheval peut aussi comme ici en ce
beau être un sport d'équipé
ah ça bouge beaucoup et ça sort un peu
de l'équitation classique dans le sens
où mais j'en ai plusieurs
et les bretons avec des films comme le
sport collectif
la première fois ses enfants mettent le
pied à l'étrier
le poney sans doute le meilleur exemple
de la démocratisation du cheval plus de
1200 plein existe en france deux cent
mille jeunes en font régulièrement
parfois que d'un grand événement plus il
fait beau alors le cheval aussi comme
activité économique
ce secteur génère 200 mille emplois
directs il y encore beaucoup à faire
si on les incitera à monter à cheval ce
qu'ils vont faire c'est qu'ils vont se
tourner vers le vtt vers la moto tout
terrain qui est le contraire en jean
d'une fuite une érosion de devises
la pratique de l'équitation le coup est
venu à 3000 francs par an en moyenne
en attendant au sport tas aujourd'hui en
france était magnifique
sans mon frère fait de côtoyer les
chaussées et coire